[Musique]
les enjeux industriels de la fabrication
additive sont extrêmement importants et
sont liées à la nature même de la
fabrication additive ou 3d printing on
va apporter la matière là où on en a
besoin est juste là où on en a besoin et
ça c'est extrêmement important parce que
ça va nous permettre d'alléger les
pièces ça va nous permettre de fusionner
des fonctions ça va nous permettre
d'éviter des assemblages et de multitude
de pièces la fabrication a dit il ça va
être aussi le moyens d'imprimer des
formes tout à fait nouvelles qui vont
libérer les designers des contraintes
actuelles des procédés génériques
c'est un enjeu important pour nous
puisque en fait dans l'aéronautique la
masse elle est extrêmement importante on
va chercher à maximiser l'utilisation du
potentiel de l'avion pour transporter
des bases des passagers et du fret
c'est également un enjeu pour nous que
de faciliter la réparation et la
maintenabilité de nos moyens
au travers de ce que je viens de dire on
peut entendre des enjeux de
certification ce qui signifie que du
point de vue de la simulation du
contrôle de la compréhension intime du
procédé
la fabrication additive présente des
challenge et additifs factory iob va
nous aider à relever ce challenge
tout au long du site depuis les pièces
les plus simples jusqu'aux pièces les
plus complexes et les plus critiques
on va se focaliser dans un premier temps
à additifs factory iob sur le métal
puisque c'est là que le plateau de
saclay nous offre le plus de potentiel
encore une fois dans le domaine de la de
la simulation de la métallurgie on va
à voir on a affaire avec la fabrication
additive à une métallurgie très
spécifique en relation avec le dépôt
d'énergie qui est lié au laser qui est
liée aux faisceaux d'électrons qui est
liée aux également au plasma et là
encore dans le domaine de des sources
d'énergie on trouve des compétences sur
le plateau de saclay qui vont être
fédérer au sein de ce hub
aditi factory iob va permettre
d'adresser des problématiques de la
fabrication additive métallique en
adressant une métallurgie très
spécifiques
on n'est pas sur la fonderie on n'est
pas sur la forge on est dans un domaine
tout nouveau qui nécessite encore
beaucoup de recherches pour aller plus
vite cet aspect vitesse est important
pour les grands groupes qui ont besoin
de rester toujours en avance dans leur
domaine mais dit yves à factory iob a
également accompagné le réseau de sous
traitants des des grands groupes dans
leurs choix techniques dans leur
expérimentation scientifique avant
d'avoir à faire des investissements très
lourds
[Musique]
au-delà de cette forte activité r&d de
la plateforme à fh qui est piloté par le
cetim et coopérer avec avec le ceva il y
aura aussi une forte activité de
transfert de la technologie en
fabrication additive vers les pme à
travers l'organisation d'un certain
nombre de formations ou d'accompagnement
qu'on peut faire en s'appuyant sur des
équipements des outils logiciels que
nous aurons au sein de la fh nous
pourront accompagner les pme à réfléchir
sur l'intégration de cette technologie
dans leur processus de paix au signal à
la conception la simulation la
fabrication le post traitement et le
contrôle voire la certification de leurs
produits
donc tous ces équipements de la fh
serviront également vos transferts de
technologie envers les pme de la région
ile-de-france sur avec les missions du
sit in qui sont vraiment les missions de
transfert de technologie pour la
mécanique française
la fh et l'écosystème autour de la
fabrication additive créé à saclay
attire beaucoup de pme d'ailleurs une
pme spécialisée dans l'impression de
polymères s'est déjà installé au sein
des locaux de la fh
[Musique]